more than 50% of adult Americans have at
least one chronic health condition
Silicon Valley is now trying to take the
lead in helping people monitor
themselves tech companies are
introducing products that promise to
help users keep a constant eye on their
health including blood pressure glucose
levels and heart problems the so called
wearable hospital is a more than six
billion dollar industry and it is
growing a market research group says the
business is expected to more than double
to 14 billion dollars worldwide by 2022
but while the products offer hope many
people have security and privacy
concerns
Brian Cooley editor at large with our
partners at C net is here good morning
Brian
morning so you have on your wrist a very
fancy looking watch what is it how does
it work this is the first time a
blood-pressure machine an actual
blood-pressure machine has been put into
a watch form so it's a marvel of
miniaturization from a company called
Imran they call it the health view
product and what you do is you just
press this one button here or it can be
automatically programmed to take tests
when needed and when you do that it goes
into this little countdown and you can't
see it but I can feel the cuff which is
the band tightening around my veins it
presses those down and then releases
again just like the big sphygmomanometer
which is that machine at the clinic so
it's FDA cleared it's not some piece of
junk that's fly-by-night it's doing the
same thing miniaturized relays the data
to an app keeps a history that you can
see on the app that shows you what your
context is so it doesn't just give you
information it'll give you answers
here's how you're trending which is what
consumers need and Eickhoff releases at
a certain date it's actually got
safeguards built in it's got redundant
vowels and electronics so it never stays
locked there are also two Medicare
accepted glucose monitors how do those
work that's right you've got one here
this is a little tiny thing that I'm
showing here in a display case it's
called the free style Libre from Abbott
and you stick this thing on your arm on
the back of your upper arm stays there
for ten days and then when you want to
read your blood glucose you just take
this little reader right here and you
just swipe it right next to the thing
and it'll read in the future pending new
approval you'll use your smart phone
it'll just be like paying at the
register you'll just swipe and there's
your glucose information without doing
anything like finger sticks and you keep
it on do you shower with it
absolutely it stays stuck on there
again ten days at a time the Europeans
allow you to work for 14 days at a time
different regulatory outlook but it's
the same thing and Medicare has picked
this up for coverage again this is
fda-cleared blood pressure and glucose
levels are two separate things why do
people need for both of them that kind
of immediate real-time feedback John
once you bring that together and also
atrial fibrillation which we've got a
sensor here this is an Apple watch band
that does EKG and atrial fibrillation
detection it's when your heart is
beating out of whack that all can come
into areas of pretty things stroke for
example combined blood pressure and afib
together and you can get a FDA cleared
initial prediction that you're trending
to or maybe away from a likelihood of a
future stroke
what are the ideas to get way in front
of things and stop doing heroic amazing
interventions later and be decades ahead
of it you live today it's like we're
driving a car where the dashboard only
works one hour a year during checkup and
the rest of the year we're driving
around no idea if our car's overheating
or has no oil who would live that way
and what is the alive core cardio band
that's the one here that does the afib
and the heart detection yes so it's
actually an EKG machine in a wristband
that you put on an Apple watch now or
they also have one that sticks on the
back of the phone so when you're seeing
they're watching video like we all do in
the horizontal format your fingers are
already there why not take an EKG Brian
this is a lot of personal information
that weird is zooming around there has
to be some privacy or security concerns
about all this data of course and of all
the new areas of innovation wearables
smart home and connected car there's
three big new ones I actually have the
least concern I have concerns by the
least concerns about this because it has
the most adult supervision
you've got very conservative healthcare
payers health care providers and FDA all
overseeing it I wish smart-home had that
much regulation I wish connected cars
had that much although that's not bad
either so if there's any area that I'm a
little s concerned it's here but yeah
this is gonna be a new frontier we have
to get consumers warmed up to the
benefits are so vast we all need to be
wearing this whether we have a condition
or not pay more attention to our
personal health in front of it thank you
so much that's right thank you